Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today, I’m
going to explain a film based on the
real-life story of the youngest warrior
of World War II called “Soldier Boy.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie begins in Russia where a family
of three sit by the river, enjoying their
time. The youngest of them, Sergei Alyoshkov,
boasts to his elder brother and mother about
him being on top of a tree, when suddenly,
German fighter jets fly overhead. The mother asks
her kids to quickly hide in the bushes, but the
six-year-old claims he is not scared and strikes
the jet with a slingshot. To everyone’s surprise,
he manages to hit the jets and explode them. But
when he looks around, his family is gone. Sergei
wakes up frightened from the dream and calls for
his mother. Just then, someone knocks on his door.
Assuming it is his mother, he runs towards
it, but a neighbor woman comes in panicking.
She thanks God for keeping him alive, and informs
him that his mother and brother are dead. The
little boy cannot comprehend what she is saying,
and wants to stay in the house to wait for his
mother. The woman tells him that the Germans have
attacked them and that he should run away.
Just then, some soldiers approach their house. The
woman makes Sergei run out through the window but
is shot dead before she can join him. The little
six-year-old is now on his own, with no family and
friends. As Sergei runs away from the house, he
sees his whole neighborhood burning behind him.
He calls for his mother in vain, and runs
away from there. After running for a while,
he ends up in the middle of the woods. The
little kid starts to call for his mother to
come and get him, because he is lost. That night,
he stays in the jungle. The following morning,
we see him drink water from a river,
when the enemy soldiers approach his way.
Sergei, knowing that they are dangerous,
quickly hides inside a tree's roots.
He is startled when a snake comes nearby,
but doesn’t utter a word or run away.
Sergei is more scared of the soldiers than of the
snake. The soldiers eat by the river and go away,
after which Sergei takes their leftover
food and devours it for the night.
However, by the end of the day, the little boy is
exhausted. He hasn’t had a proper meal in two days
and has been walking with no destination. He falls
down as he limps but doesn’t stop walking. While
on his way, he sees wild berries and devours them;
but just then, an explosion occurs behind him,
taking him by surprise. The boy gets dizzy, and
starts to hallucinate someone coming behind him.
However, even in such conditions, he stands
brave and tells the person he has a rifle
and is not scared. He limps forward
but falls unconscious after a while.
While he is asleep, two soldiers approach him.
The scene cuts to the Russian army base where
Commander Kuznetsov waits for his patrol
soldiers. They come in with the little kid
who is injured and weak. When the soldiers claim
they are on his side, the little boy opens up and
introduces himself. The soldiers laugh when
the kid shakes his hand with the commander,
suggesting he introduce himself too.
The soldiers feel affectionate with
the little kid, and circle him around.
They make him drink water and feed him.
Even the otherwise cold commander takes care of
the kid. A nurse named Katya dresses Sergei’s
wounds, and is charmed by his personality too. The
kid asks her to draw a tank on his wounds, because
he wants to be a soldier when he grows up. Even
the injured soldiers talk to the kid, and feel
lighter. Sergei is fascinated with the commander’s
gun and his batch. The commander too answers all
the little boy’s questions and lets him play with
his honorary pistol after taking the bullets out.
Sergei shows him the tank drawn on his stomach,
and boasts about being a soldier himself. The boy
is healing very quickly. The nurse Katya asks the
commander to let the boy stay with the battalion,
but he disagrees, claiming that it won’t be safe;
he wants to send Sergei to an orphanage. The
soldiers spent all their free time with Sergei.
He is visited by many throughout the day. They
bring him food sent by their families from afar,
and even let him play with their binoculars.
One day, a soldier goes to the commander to
ask him to let the boy stay with the battalion.
The soldiers have grown a close connection
with the kid, and think of him as their own.
His presence takes the weight of war off their
chest. However, the commander is adamant about
sending the boy to the orphanage, for his own
safety. The following day, the enemies attack,
and many soldiers are hurt. A vehicle comes to
fetch Sergei to take him to the orphanage. The
commander breaks the news to the kid ,and gives
him a wooden honorary pistol as a gift. The boy
in turn hugs him, claiming that he is scared for
the commander’s safety. The commander melts in his
embrace, and changes his mind. He asks Sergei to
stay with the soldiers as his son. That night, the
soldiers look for little soldier clothes for the
little boy, they are over the moon to have Sergei
stay with them. The commander wakes Sergei up
and gives him the clothes. He wears them and runs
around, looking like a real soldier. The others
start calling him their little soldier boy.
As the kid runs around, the Germans launch an air
attack on the battalion. The soldiers quickly take
Sergei to a safe place and fight the others. The
number of injured soldiers grows rapidly. Sergei
wants to make himself useful, so he brings water
to thirsty soldiers. One of them asks him to read
a letter sent by his family because he has a
bandage over his eyes. The little boy wants to
help, but doesn’t know how to read. He takes the
letter and starts making up the things written on
it, claiming that the soldier’s cow is safe back
home. When the soldier says he doesn’t have a cow,
the others tell him to go along with the story
and laugh. He reads everyone else’s letters
in the same fashion and cheers them up.
In the following scene, we see Katya and the
Commander talking. The two seem to be attracted
to each other, but do not confess their feelings.
Later, Sergei tells the Commander that he is of
the orderly position in the battalion and starts
introducing himself as one. However, the boy then
sees one of the soldier’s station destroyed from
the attack. The commander teaches him to take his
hat off to pay respect to the dead soldier.
The next day, he insists the commander give him
a mission and is given a task to distribute the
letters among the soldiers. He completes his
task efficiently and even makes the soldiers
dance for him. The following day, Sergei goes
a little far from the base with his binoculars.
As he is playing with it, he sees someone’s leg
moving from inside a haystack, he rushes back to
the battalion and tells the soldiers about
his findings. The soldiers are skeptical,
but go with the boy anyway. When they reach near
the haystack, they are alerted to see two German
spies hiding underneath. The spies are arrested,
and the kid is praised for his intelligence.
That night, the commander shows Sergei the legal
papers for his adoption. He is now officially the
kid’s father. Sergei knows of the commander’s
feelings for Katya, so, to repay his kindness,
he takes him to confess to her. But the two see
her talking to a different man, and wrongfully
assume she is interested in someone else.
The base is attacked by the Germans again.
This time, Sergei helps the soldiers with all his
might, by supplying ammunition to the soldiers in
the frontline, but the soldiers there command him
to go back to the shed because it is too dangerous
outside. When he comes to the shed, he sees the
commander and others panicking because the phone’s
connection with the colonel is lost. A soldier is
sent to fix the broken wires. Sergei follows the
soldier and sees he has been fatally wounded. He
asks the dying soldier how he can fix the wires,
and does it himself. The connection
comes back and more troops are called.
The six years old saves everyone’s life.
Later, we see the commander and Katya talking
by the river. The commander finally confesses his
love for her and asks her to be Sergei’s mother.
Katya is over the moon, but before she can say
anything, a soldier approaches them and gives
the commander a letter, saying they have been
dispatched from the base. The following day,
all the soldiers leave for their new base
along with Sergei. However, on their way,
they come across a minefield that blows off some
of their vehicles. The commander is hurt while the
group’s orderly, who Sergei was close with, dies
in the explosion. He cries and hugs the commander.
They carry the injured ones with them and
continue their journey to their new base.
When they finally reach the other
base, they meet the commander’s leader,
the General. He too is impressed by the kid’s
ambition, and congratulates the commander for
having such a smart kid. The following day,
their division is awarded a guard’s banner,
and so is the boy. He promises to save his
country when the general gives him his batch.
One night, their base is attacked brutally,
and the commander is trapped under the ruins.
Sergei cries for his father and tries to
save him. He calls the other soldiers,
who finally bring the commander out.
The next day, Sergei approaches an
injured commander, his hands were hurt
while trying to save the commander.
The kid is now an inseparable part of the team.
He doesn’t have a family beside them, and moves
wherever they go in the war. The movie ends as
the regiment is seen moving to another base.
A voice in the background narrates that he
even took part in the Stalingrad battle,
and reached Poland with the soldiers. He is
currently known as the world’s youngest soldier
ever, and the legendary story of his bravery,
is now spread for the whole world to hear.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on notifications,
and leave a like to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.